[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
Morris I prefer to think of it Dear John
and Hank it's a podcast where me and my
brother John give you dubious advice
answer your questions and bring you all
the week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon and man as the Mars news good
this week the big Mars news week Hank
and but I would argue an even bigger AFC
Wimbledon news week you know what we
found in South London at AFC Wimbledon
Stadium you will not believe this well
maybe you should save it for the news
occasionally Hank not all the time but
occasionally there is flowing water in
Kings meadow in South London AFC
Wimbledon's Stadium they probably should
level the field oh man oh boy it's
exciting it's exciting all right John
how you doing I'm doing well um you know
how am i doing I don't know I'm working
on a story and I'm trying to stay in the
story and hid a word count everyday and
so it's a little bit disorienting to try
to interact with the with the regular
world but I'm on the whole doing well I
can't I've been writing a lot down by
the river
which has been lovely and it's just
beautiful here in Indianapolis ever
since Taylor Swift left a few weeks ago
she left but the weather that she
brought has stayed it's almost like as
long as we can hold on to the memory of
the magic night of Taylor Swift's
concert here in Indianapolis winter will
never come how are you I'm fantastic I
launched a wizard school Kickstarter
yesterday I'm making a game it's called
wizard school and when I say yesterday I
mean yesterday as of the recording not
as of the uploading of this podcast and
it's going very well and I'm very
excited and it's kind of taking over my
life and has been for a while but at
least now it's taking over my life and I
can talk about it which is exciting yeah
it's a really cool card game I have not
played it yet but I was one of your
first ten Kickstarter backers oh thanks
I meant I just I am amazed by your
ability to continue to make stuff and I
know that you love card games so I'm
psyched
that you get to finally make one and I
love like the idea of a wizard school
that is not so
Hogwarts e'en that's like more like a
normal high school that just happens to
have a lot of people with special powers
yeah I mean it's it's you know you're
going about your daily lives and
sometimes it's gonna be a normal school
thing that you might expect and
sometimes it's gonna be a score Pelican
that's loose in the school and it's it's
affecting everybody's magical abilities
and and you have to either kill it or
you know do do a number of other things
it's there's a lot of choice involved in
the game you know like a lot of things
that you and then sometimes the game
forces you to do things and and and then
there's a lot of for me when I'm playing
the game it's a lot about card
management and figuring out like okay I
could do this but do I want to do I want
to save this for a better time and it's
very it's a lot of tension it's really
fun and I'm excited to to be doing this
yes you can go to Kickstarter and check
out the wizard school card game that
Hank has invented with some of his
friends
the first project from Hanks new company
dftba games just go to Kickstarter comm
and search for wizard school I am
genuinely excited about this Hank I
don't talk about your projects that I
think are less cool I just ignore them
completely but I think this one is great
I would say that your two greatest
achievements as an entrepreneur number
one 2d glasses of course oh yeah of
course you know that that render
three-dimensional movies in a crisp two
dimensions and then number two a head of
VidCon this card game I haven't played
yet now right well I actually am excited
that I made 2d glasses because the
Martian is coming out very soon and will
have come out by the time this podcast
uploads and it's in 3d and I want to see
it in 3d but Katherine does not and so
I'm gonna bring her with me but she's
gonna get to watch it in 2d Hank would
you like a short poem for today is your
is your short poem about 2d glasses it
is not it is about grief okay sure sorry
to ruin your day it's by Raymond Carver
it's called grief woke up early this
morning and from my bed looked far
across the straight to see a small boat
moving through the choppy water
a single running light on remembered my
friend who used to shout his dead wife's
name from hilltops around Perugia who
set a plate for her at his simple table
long after she was gone and opened the
windows so she could have fresh air
such display I found embarrassing so did
his other friends I couldn't see it not
until this morning grief by Raymond
Carver I love that poem really gets me
gets me like just below the solar plexus
mmm that's a soft spot I can tell that
you prefer the funny poems I well I was
a little bit unable to keep the train of
thought on that one my my dog was being
cute can I tell you a poem that I think
is quite funny that's two lines long by
Ogden Nash okay sure I think it's
actually four lines long candy is dandy
but liquor is quicker that is those are
some short lines if that's a four line
poem yeah I thought you would like that
one because it's funny but maybe you're
just paying attention to your dog
instead of listening to me I did I know
I did I did I liked it I've heard it
before
in fact I didn't ever consider it as so
much a poem as some people say hang
should we answer some questions from our
beloved listeners let's do that we've
got one from Siena who asks dear Hank
and John I've recently joined the Model
UN at my high school I'm super excited
but kind of nervous I've never been
ashamed of being a nerd but I was
wondering how to not be pressured or
hurt when people make fun of you doing
nerdy things I know being a nerd is
wonderful and you should embrace embrace
your nerdiness but high school is hard
and scary and full of peer pressure so
before we get to CNS excellent question
Hank I just have to tell you that I was
in the Model UN in high school for those
who don't know the Model UN is a it's a
thing where young people pretend to be
in the United Nations pretend to
represent certain countries and have
sort of a model United Nations and I I
was a really bad Model UN person I
thought one of my problems in high
school was that I wasn't able to like
empathetically imagine what it was like
to be anyone
other than myself so it was really
difficult for me to like be told to play
the role of you know whatever country I
was being told to play the role of and
my most memorable Model UN tournament or
whatever it was called
I was turkey and I really liked the the
girl who was Russia she was great she
was funny she was really smart she had
ideas and so I co-sponsored a lot of her
resolutions because I thought they were
just excellent even like she would be
like I think that that that Russia which
at the time was it was a new nation that
had emerged out of the Soviet Union
should have access to some Turkish ports
and I was like you know that's not a bad
idea why are we hogging all of our ports
you know like it's not we're not poor
Russia has no warm water ports and we're
just sitting here on the Mediterranean
you know it's not like we can't share so
yeah I am NOT the person to tell you how
to be good at Model UN but I am really
nerdy so I can say something about that
but Hank you're even nerdier so you
answered the place I don't like I felt
that and I rebelled against try looking
nerdy and and tried to not look nerdy
while also trying to not lose my
identity and but like yeah I I think
that what I noticed was no matter what
skin I put on no matter what you know
click I was a part of no one like that
there weren't any because I lived to a
really big high school there weren't any
that were under the radar
there weren't any that were above
everyone else everyone made fun of
everyone else at my high school and
nobody was cool there may have been some
groups that were that were ignored and
that was probably the best that you
could be but there was there was even
like the people who everybody's sort of
like saw as the popular powerful people
in school even they got ripped apart in
terms of like people tearing them down
and I I don't know if that's something
that happens only at big schools or if
that's something that ever
experiences but what I've noticed is
that it's not it's not about trying to
figure out how how to not get torn down
it's about trying to figure out how to
be confident enough in the stuff that
you like that it doesn't you know ruin
your day when it happens yeah and also
how to not be a terror down but instead
to be a builder up and I think you know
if you focus on stuff that you love and
stuff that you feel excited and
passionate about and you know try to not
focus so much on that that that like
fear and negativity that is a huge part
of any social order but especially
probably high school social orders I
think I think things get a lot better
because you love the stuff that you love
and you know something about why you
love it and you have friends and lots of
other people who like make make your
life better who share some of those
interests and what people outside of
that think matters less when you can
find that real pleasure and passion in
the stuff that you do yeah and that
that's where a lot of that confidence to
sort of like to like shrug off of
unpleasant interaction comes from when
you really when you really believe in
the coolness of the thing and if
somebody else disagrees with that then
that's because they disagree with it and
if they're being mean that's because
they're mean nothing wrong with you good
for you Hank I love that answer we have
another question this one is from a
grown up act like a proper adult
listener of Dear John and Hank we love
our adult listeners there's lots of
those I know
in fact it's mostly adult listeners they
just don't send it as many questions all
right it's anyway Hank the question is
from amber who writes Dear John and Hank
marriage is hard work I love my husband
more than anything but as my career is
taking off I'm traveling for long
periods of time and it's difficult to
stay connected and communicate
effectively my husband is extremely
happy at his home town nine to five job
but I work for a large corporation that
sends me all over and sometimes requires
I work from dawn to dusk since both of
you seemed to travel and work for a
large majority of your life do you have
any advice on ways to stay connected
wall apart sorry for the serious topic
but who are we kidding your podcast
isn't always comedy Thank You amber for
your wonderful question first off our
podcast is hilarious that rain
carver poem that i read earlier today
was riotous i would describe it as
riotous depart where he talked about the
dead the the guy opening the window so
that his dead wife could have air to
breathe it's just haha yeah i mean this
is i think this is a really difficult
thing in a lot of marriages is balancing
you know that the needs of one's career
or you know their urges ones ones career
ambitions and business ambitions with
one's personal ambitions and i think a
lot of it too is for me a ton of it is
being respectful of your partner and
their their choices and so not trying to
judge the person who has a nine-to-five
hometown job not trying to see one or
the other of those ways of being as
better that can be very difficult when
obviously like you you like your way of
being and want to defend it but i don't
think that those kind of like defenses
of my way is the best way necessarily
make relationships better but it's
something that I struggle with a lot and
I'm one of the big reasons that I travel
a lot less these days I mean Sarah
travels a lot for her work with the art
assignment and I still travel you know a
fair bit but I used to travel 150 days a
year and that was just too much for me
because it was difficult for us to stay
connected and I just felt like I wasn't
as much a part of my family's life as I
really needed to be and wanted to be so
I cut way back on travel in the last
year and it's been great i but you know
it seems like amber you want to you're
in a part of your life and a part of
your career where you want to be taking
those opportunities and you want to be
traveling the world and doing whatever
you do working for that large
corporation and you know and then you've
just got a you've just got to keep the
lines of communication open I have I I
believe that it is basically impossible
to have like really high quality
conversations in a marriage when you got
you're on the road and you're
doing like fundamentally different
things actually I don't know if I
believe that I don't know I should let
Hank talk why am I just talking you did
yeah I mean you got to most of the
points I mean I'm a little concerned
when anyone says that they're working
dawn to dusk because I I you know you
know in the same breath is saying that
their their you know their marriage is
the most important thing to them or they
love their husband more than anything
else I mean like I I try so hard to not
have the people who work for me do that
and sometimes they want to and and but
like you know for me I don't like I
don't think that like I try to not ask
that of people and I I if I was in a
situation where my employer was asking
that of me I would I would not want to
be in that situation but I also like you
know when I am my own boss I absolutely
sometimes work that way and so like
there is there's you know validity to
that and excitement in that and as long
as it's not personally draining or or
draining in your relationships but yeah
I think John hit most the important
parts of this which is like you know you
guys have to like recognize that both of
you want to do a thing and and being
open and allowing for that is is great
and and I you know I think doing it
while apart is hard and so like the best
thing you can do is when you're together
have have you know consistent and and
high-quality interactions where you
don't have your phone out and you are
you know talking about how like not just
what happened but how you feel about
what happened and and how you feel about
life and how you feel about the place
where you live and and how you feel
about you know the next 5-10 years the
things that are gonna happen to you and
and like the things that the things of
deep relationships yeah and taking each
other's work and concerns seriously and
with like yeah well seriousness I think
that's really important like in in it I
had this like weird period in my career
where like there were movies being made
and I was like what did you do today at
work well I talked to the Today Show and
you
and and it's easy to to imagine that
like that is like more interesting or
more important than what someone else
did and if you do that it's you're
doomed I start to believe that I really
have your doom and like I felt like I
almost had to pull back from some of
that stuff because otherwise it was just
like I was going to start to believe
that that that stuff was inherently more
important and more interesting than like
you know Henry going to soccer practice
like the other day I took Henry to his
soccer game and it was a great be played
great I know that you're curious Hank he
played amazingly the kid is just he's
gonna he's a future star of AFC
Wimbledon but after the game he was like
going through every single time he
touched the ball and I realized that
like to Henry it was incredibly
important like it was as important to
him as an AFC Wimbledon game is to me
and that I really needed to like listen
to him and try to treat treat it
seriously even though it's five-year-old
soccer and like they're all you know
technically horrible yeah the other
thing I would say Hank is I'm a big fan
of Google Hangouts like I believe in
looking someone in the eye I think it
just makes a difference
we've been on this question a long time
but I want to add one last thing which
is that we have many projects in our
life and John was just saying like how
do you like Hank has so many things and
he does all the things and and I think
that it is important to not think of
your relationships in your life is
something that just happened and that
are there but that are continuous
projects that you are working on and in
in many ways the most important projects
in my life are my relationships and I
want to cultivate them and I want to
build them and I want them to be
interesting and different just that in
the same way that I want to cultivate
and make interesting and different and
successful my businesses so like like
just in the same way that I want to
focus on my career I think that it like
focusing on relationships as a project
and like focusing on you know child
rearing as a project like obviously
making it like creating a human is
probably the biggest project that people
ever engage in you know any individual I
don't care if it's Elon Musk or if it's
John Green or if it's you know you like
like those things that we do like that's
how the next like it's not just that's
like you know this is something that
we're building for people this is like
we're creating the next generation of
people and without that there would be
no more people anymore yeah it is
overwhelmingly the most important part
of my life and the most important kind
of project in my life is my is my family
now I'm very lucky that like for me you
know Hank is part of my family and we
get to collaborate together on a lot of
work stuff and that feels like both work
and family stuff but there's also a lot
of like private family stuff in my life
you know I don't talk with ton about my
kids or my marriage and but that's by
far the most important thing I mean
there's yeah and I think you have to
remember that it's it's hard to
prioritize particularly you know because
there can be some excitement and and
intrigue and kind of jolt enos around
around work and professional success and
you get a lot of outside encouragement
and outside affirmation but for me at
least like the family the family
projects those have to be in the very
very center of things alright John we
got another question this one is from
new Myra who says dear Hank and John I'm
finding it harder and harder to form an
opinion of a lot of compelling political
problems in the world because I keep
imagining complexly my opinion keeps
getting split both ways what do you
think I should do about that onew Myra I
think you should celebrate yeah that's
great news Niemeyer congratulations I
mean it might make it harder to figure
out who to vote for but that means that
you are that most valuable and
interesting of of constituents the swing
voter yeah no we need more swing voters
we need more like high-interest really
dedicated knowledgeable thoughtful swing
voters people who don't know which way
to vote despite knowing lots of things
into some
that might sound completely impossible
if you are educated than you must know
but look
50% of America votes one way and 50%
votes the other way I mean not exactly
obviously but pretty much and so what
you're saying is if you're if you're
educated then you're definitely gonna
fall on one of those two sides no you're
gonna like some people are gonna fall in
the middle and I often find myself
thinking you know like if I'm really
paying attention not to the news and not
to that you know not to read it not to
the blogs I follow but to what
candidates are saying I will
occasionally be like yes no that makes
sense when I'm listening to someone who
on other subjects I'm like you need to
pull your head out of your butt sir
because that is an inexcusable way to
think and it's it's interesting that I
could think that way about a person that
some of their ideas are good and some
are bad but of course you can because
that's how people are yeah we have such
a personality driven political culture
and I understand why that's valuable and
good in a lot of ways but we never talk
about actual policy like we so rarely
talk about actual policy positions you
know we're constantly having these
arguments about the underlying
ideologies but like let's talk about
what you would actually do and I think
when you talk about what we what you
would actually do you find that a lot
more people are swing voters you know
and right but so I think that well if we
focus on policy then you do see that
this is it's not as black and white and
it's it becomes a lot more of an
interesting conversation now political
candidates are reluctant for many
reasons to focus on policy for one thing
I don't think they think that it gets
them votes but also you know it puts
them in the position of likely breaking
campaign promises down the road but I
think I think that when you focus on
that when you focus on like what people
are actually proposing and what the
implications of it are the conversations
can get a lot more interesting and also
less like heated and rhetorical yes okay
this question is from Katie who writes
Dear John and Hank after struggling for
a few years out of college I finally
managed to find a full-time job
congratulations Katie I'm grateful to be
able to support myself
but it's for a business market I think
is pretty morally ambiguous how do I
help myself justify going to work every
day supporting something I don't believe
in oh that's a big one boy the first
thing that I would say is that every
business is a little morally ambiguous
right like I am I try very hard and I
know Hank tries very hard to to create
an environment here where we're working
on you know crash course and scishow and
Mental Floss video and art assignment
like stuff that people can feel really
passionate and good about but make no
mistake lots of things about my work are
morally problematic like there's a lot
of things about the book business for
instance that are that really troubled
me particularly some of the business
practices of the largest booksellers in
the country Walmart Target and Amazon I
know that it is alarming that those are
our three largest bookstores in the US
but they are and I and and yet I still
believe in writing novels and I still
and I still go to work that said like
that's so I I don't want you to think
that there's some like shimmering city
on a hill out there where you know you
can work in a field that's that's
totally removed from any kind of like
ethical problem but like one of my good
friends is a rocket engineer who is
designing engines for warplanes and that
is very troubling to him and I
definitely understand why it is
troubling to him and I don't have an
easy answer for that so hopefully Hank
will you know I don't know any specifics
Katty of where you're working what
you're doing I you know if you if you're
working for a drug kingpin killing
people then I would definitely be
concerned but if you're working for you
know Walmart as a as like a you know
logistics person how to get food to one
place to from one place to another like
you know Walmart is troubling in some
ways but it's also it also solves
problems and there's a reason why
Walmart is successful and there's a
reason why people go
you know like there's reason why people
work at Walmart there's the people
reason why people go and shop at Walmart
and you know the there's definitely I
think you should probably ask new Myra
about this because she might or he I'm
guessing she cuz it ends at an a would
have a good a good set of thoughts on
you know like the you know the ambiguity
of it like there there is good being
done and there's bad being done and the
question always is is the good
outweighing the bad and like I as a
person who is you know really really
concerned about climate change hate the
fact that I get on a plane like once a
month to go to a place to have a
business meeting or to like hang out
with family or you know to go to LA to
talk to a bunch of my youtuber friends
you know that is troubling to me and you
know when I ask myself is this you know
is it worth that you know adding to the
tremendous problem that we are going to
have to face of climate change I'm never
quite sure and like and and that's just
a like moral ambiguity is part of I
think being a human definitely part of
being a human in today's society so yeah
the other thing that I would say is that
a lot of times you don't have good
choices you know like it's not your
fault if you don't have good choices in
this situation and like it's it's it's
it's an easy choice to make if you're
choosing between you know jobs that pay
the same amount and allow you to take
care of yourself and your family where
where one is you know like doing
development work somewhere in an
underserved community and the other is
like you know like murderer for a drug
kingpin but like the truth is that like
almost all of us like live in the middle
and we have limited choices and you have
to make like the best choices that you
can make while still acknowledging the
fact that you have to take care of
yourself so I think it's more of like a
spectrum than it is an easy yes or no
I'm reminded of the great resignation
letter that the novelist William
Faulkner wrote to the United States
servus when he when he quit his job
working for the post office in
Mississippi Hank are you familiar with
this letter no well this letter is the
best advice I can I can give I guess
because um it acknowledges the fact that
we are all going to be influenced by
capitalism but also acknowledges that at
least in Faulkner's case a limit had
been reached this is the letter in its
entirety as long as I live under the
capitalistic system I expect to have my
life influenced by the demands of
moneyed people but I will be damned if I
propose to be at the beck and call of
every itinerant scoundrel who has two
cents to invest in a postage stamp this
sir is my resignation my last piece of
advice for Katy is that is to not lose
sight of the moral ambiguity to know
that it's there and as you rise as you
have more career opportunities as you're
able to do more as you have access to
more resources recognize that there are
other things that you could do or inside
or outside of your organization to to
make those places to make those
organizations better and like has really
you know we talk a lot about how
capitalism is the thing that that drives
everything in America but it is really a
mix of both capitalism and human culture
that are the the the thing that shapes
what this country is and and like the
fact that this you know this weird you
know divorced from reality market thing
has such a massive effect it's kind of
can be terrifying but but it really it
cannot it cannot make us make decisions
we make decisions and every you know
every decision everything that a
corporation does is a decision made by a
human being and so like be good human
being even if you are in a place where
the thing that that you know you might
not believe in the thing that that your
company is doing be a good human being
within that and that that will that can
change heck I think we have to move on
to the news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon
I think that we'll do the news from AFC
Wimbledon for
because from what I understand it was a
big week on Mars um now Hank you may
remember that in 2011 the AFC Wimbledon
having risen from the ninth tier of
English football was on the cusp of
returning to the Football League the
full-time professional football leagues
at the top four leagues in England their
full-time professional teams and then
below that it's a mature semi-pro a
couple professional teams but mostly
sort of varying degrees of amateur that
fifth tier the one that you have to win
or finish or win the playoffs in to get
to to get to League Two which is the the
bottom rung of the Football League is
called the conference or it was at the
time anyway and AFC Wimbledon made it to
the last game the play-off final and
they were playing Luton Town and it was
a nil nil draw at the end of 90 minutes
there was 30 minutes of extra time then
it was still a nil nil draw and then
there was a shootout and 19 year-old Seb
Brown the goalkeeper for AFC Wimbledon
saved two penalties Danny Cadwell the 33
year old journeyman who'd never played a
game in the Football League and his life
scored the decisive penalty AFC
Wimbledon's captain he ran to the fans
who owned AFC Wimbledon together
collectively it was an amazing amazing
moment AFC Wimbledon were back in the
Football League after the horrors that
had befallen them at the beginning of
the century it was one of the greatest
moments in sports history well a couple
years later Luton Town got promoted to
the Football League as well so now Luton
Town and AFC Wimbledon are in the same
league and they just played their first
game against each other since that
magical night in Manchester
when AFC Wimbledon were promoted to the
league and Luton Town won and AFC
Wimbledon lost let's move on to the news
from Mars oh man well that was some
really long brief news job
I yes so so first I did want to say that
as of the release of this podcast the
Martian is in theaters I haven't seen it
yet because as of the recording of this
podcast it isn't out yet I'm very
excited about it though and I'm probably
going to like it and so you should go
see it that's kind of Mars news but in
addition there's an some actual very
exciting Mars news which is that they
have they we really the human race has
found that there is supersalty
flowing water on the surface of Mars
it's it's not like a river it's more
like sort of trickles through wet sand
kind of muddy stuff it's coming out of
really steep you know cliff sides
craters glia and valleys and it's the
the big question is you know where is
this stuff coming from and the the you
know most obvious potential answer is
that it is in fact flowing out of liquid
water that is below the surface of Mars
now there are some other potential
mechanisms for this but it's probably
that there is a lot of liquid water
below the surface of Mars and it just
happens that in these places and in
these particular circumstances it's able
to flow out and persist for a large
amount of time on the surface so there's
a lot of water on Mars and it turns out
that isn't it isn't just ice there's
there's quite a lot of liquid water on
Mars and that is very exciting you know
it doesn't change how how livable the
planet is to us because we could you
know there's always been ice there that
we could turn into water but it does
change the potential for existing
Martian biologies and Ecology's which is
exciting because boy if we found life
somewhere else and that life was
substantially different from life here
on earth now of course it might be that
life was seeded from Earth to Mars or
from Mars to earth and and and the life
will be actually very similar but if it
was a completely new set of biology that
was based on different chemicals and
different like no DNA and no proteins
but a different kind of building block
that would be the kind of science
that would just be unthinkable to do
right now to be able to observe that to
be able to understand and and and put
that puzzle together would be one of the
great endeavors of humanity and so it's
kind of thing that people get really
excited about and wait wait wait for
good reasons yes what you're telling me
that all all human all life on Earth is
is dna/rna based right correct and
you're saying that it's possible that
Martian life is not DNA or RNA based
that it's completely separate that it
evolved completely separate yeah yeah I
mean that's like what like like how oh
we don't know that's the thing we can't
imagine another system because the
system that we have is so ridiculously
cool and complex and took us so long to
even figure out how our system works and
we have it all around us to be examining
and understanding where as trying to
come up with from scratch with another
another way to have life work is as
difficult is not that's that's hard and
and so like that what that's one of the
you know really exciting things about
you know you know Mars and Europa that
we could like observe not just life
somewhere else but life that is like as
if if life happened somewhere else it
would not be based on the exact same
system as us like that that you know
Minoo my guess is that that our you know
the way that our RNA and DNA function is
an accident of chemistry it's just the
way that it happened to happen for the
first life form on earth and if it had
happened a different way than all of us
would be very very different not just
you know not just chemically but you
know physically and in different places
where different where there's different
chemistry different different
temperatures different pressures
different stuff in the water then you
might see a completely different set of
chemistry's that would define the life
all right that's pretty cool actually
that's kind of exciting no God it's very
exciting I mean even if there's no life
involved it's very exciting because
getting to observe a different hydrology
in a geology that's based on different
chemistry and on different amounts of
gravity on different and like different
atmospheres different chemicals in the
crust you know the fact that like Mars
probably like doesn't have a liquid core
but probably still has magma somewhere
underneath the surface because the root
most recent volcanic eruptions were very
recent like there's a lot like just
having a second sample you know we have
the earth and we can study the earth but
Mars is very different and so getting to
getting like the the fact that we get to
have you know we can do increase our
sample size from 1 to 2
that's pretty massive in terms of
studying anything and so like you know
hydrologists and geologists of the world
may be a little bit less exciting for
the average human but like those people
are like that is it is the most exciting
thing in the world that that there gets
to be another world for us to study can
we back up a little you mentioned
something about Europa
what is your ropa I know that you rope a
leader of a in in Europe is like if
you're not quite good enough to get into
the Champions League like Liverpool is
then you play in the Europa League is it
similar or is it different it's
different Europa is a moon of Jupiter
and tell me more about tell me more
about this moon Europa is made of ice
probably entirely so it's just a big
ball of ice and below the surface
because of your idle pressures from
Jupiter it is liquid ice so water oh so
it's like got an icy crust but then
there's some warm ice under there's a
giant massive subsurface ocean on on
Europa and and we would very much like
to to be there and to check it out
because like it's literally like
probably the the water of Europa if you
were under the surface and you had
swimming swimming tank like it would be
awesome it would be like do you just be
like you know 80 degree water really
yeah I mean there there would be areas
of the of the planet where it would be
much hotter and much colder than that
but there would be you know bands
of you know perfectly tropical feeling
water can I ask a couple stupid
questions yes sir
why is Europa's water warm when Europa
itself is so far from the Sun Europa's
water is warmed by tidal pressures from
Jupiter so as it goes around Jupiter and
spins the Jupiter actually like
stretches the planet out a little bit
and that causes a friction and that
friction is transferred into heat which
which basically makes the entire surface
of Europa look like this weird puzzle
piece thing and has like these big
cracks and rifts in it because it's
basically as like plate tectonics
because it's the solid crust on top of
the liquid the liquid water inside
that's kind of cool it's super cool but
we couldn't live on Europa because
there's no land we could live in Europa
if we wanted to be inside of submarines
all the time
we could also live on Europa if we
wanted to be inside of you know
controlled habitats as well okay like
floaties controlled a but that's or just
like how they do it on it in Antarctica
where they build like a thing on an on a
island of ice yeah I mean it would have
to be a little more advanced than that
you'd have to have it have to be
airtight there's no atmosphere on Europa
as far as I know mmm okay you know where
we could also just stay here yeah no
absolutely I wouldn't suggest going to
live on Europa unless like we run out of
like we really run out of resources and
space but but I would definitely want
people to be there to do science on
Europa I don't think that it's a a place
to go to cheat chill yeah no I mean
you've I have to say Hank you've kind of
gotten me excited I did not I did not
get that into this Mars news but now
you've got me excited thinking about the
idea that life could have fundamentally
different building blocks elsewhere than
it does here
that's pretty mind-blowing indeed it is
not however as mind-blowing as that
moment when Seb Braun
jewelle child took 5600 people's lives
and their hands went the wrong way on a
penalty and then held up his huge glove
his right hand it was almost like I
don't I don't believe that that it was
supernatural like obviously I don't
think that God has an interest in the
outcome of football games but it felt
that way when his hand reached up the
wrong way and just got enough of the
ball and then his celebration was just
immense and then I mean the weeping
these these these these grown men and
women who'd had their football team
taken away from them by this you know
just corrupt organization and then built
it from scratch and then just though
them dissolving into tears as they
realized that they were back in the
Football League that they had a
professional team that there was going
to be football and Wimbledon it was
amazing you know so like lots of things
are amazing lots of things are amazing
and I want to say that Europa I said
that it was a ball of water it is in
fact a mostly a ball of rock but with a
with a full full water covering over it
I had that wrong so I corrected myself
before next week I feel like you might
not have been listening to me when I was
talking about how great said Browns
second penalty save was well you know
I've heard the story before oh boy
today's podcast is brought to you by
Europa Europa made of ice
possibly rock today's podcast John is
brought to you by children's soccer
games they're a monument to
understanding value in human psychology
and of course today's podcast is brought
to you by the nation of Turkey the
nation of Turkey inexplicably friendly
with Russia Russia sure is cute just
they couldn't be any sweeter yeah Hank
what did we learn today before we depart
for the fair shores we learned that the
American swing voter is in great need of
cultivation and an appreciation we
learned that marriage is hard work and
the most important work in many people's
lives we learned that all businesses
John are morally
ambiguous and of course we learned that
there is occasionally flowing water on
Mars as long as you define flowing and
water very generously it's let's water
it's just just like the ocean is water
it's just salty water and it's not
saltier than the ocean to be clear at
some point it stops being at some point
it stops being water and it just becomes
wet salt yeah that is kind of true they
called it they call it hydrated
perchlorates and and people tend to
think when you say salty water they're
like oh like the ocean so if I put it in
my mouth it would taste salty but salts
are any ionic compound and the salt in
question is not in sodium chloride it is
magnesium calcium perchlorate different
perchlorates which are not good and you
don't want them in your mouth do not put
Martian salt in your mouth do not put
that in your face one more lesson from a
comedy podcast by two brothers thanks
for listening our podcast is edited by
Nick Jenkins the theme music is from
gunnarolla if you want to send us
questions you can do that at dear Hank
and nope at Hank and John at gmail.com
no dear just Hank and John at gmail.com
and as we say in our hometown don't
forget to be awesome
[Music]